towards children a show kind of rigidly
gendered these days toys that are
marketed at girls may be less complex
why sigh one thing to a household when
you can sell to baby doll home keeping
sparkles reform pink curtains anything
focused on aesthetics boys that has to
put up with a see day action then
Bobby's my x-ray vision giant fist upon
your hand and punch star you and
workstations and stuff which is yes you
can weird I mean these are supposed to
be light in time right
so joy do we still have so much gendered
stuff pink is just a theme with the
youngest one in particular I don't know
why you started shouting nor a pink pink
pink sure little because paint so it
should be okay
I can't say I minded I bet I think it's
quite a natural thing for them to be
into princesses and stuff but I kind of
don't push them toward the in fact I
probably push them the other way
I think the reality of it is that it
starts like so so early that makes it
really hard to differentiate between
what is an innate desire and what's a
learned behavior we kind of create that
world for a gender is important the
first thing we want to know when
somebody gets pregnant or has a baby is
is it a girl or a boy
despite the absence of pretty much all
basic survival skills babies are very
good at picking up social cues right
from the moment of birth and they're
aware of the faith and the sound of a
person who might be the source of their
food so less than a year old babies are
picking up the fact that there are
gendered differences in their world so
they would respond with surprise to the
vision of a man putting on lipstick for
example young children are trying to
make sense of a really complicated world
we adults are used to have so many
different stimuli around us for young
children we need to kind of figure out
what are the rules of the world by
knowing that's a girl that's a boy so
that tells me something about them that
allows them to put their energy into
other things so then I just allow them
to just organize it in a way that is
efficient it does feel really in
Congress I think that in recent years
we've made so much headway in the way
that we talk about gender and yet at the
same time we've still got this
stubbornly binary gender marketing if
manufacturers make it so easy for
children to see this is a toy for me or
this is a toy not for
then they use that information and it
funnels them into playing with
particular toys that might influence
their play behaviors that kind of skills
they develop and their career
aspirations one of the things we've
learned is that the brain is moldable
from very early on by all sorts of
different experiences that we might have
for example experiences with
construction toys or video games is a
much better predictor of how you're
going to perform and spatial tasks than
if you're male or female I think with a
rigid view that we have of gender is
problematic for everyone so in an ideal
world we would have more openness about
gender and I think that would be better
for everyone in terms of women's
opportunities and in terms of male
progression in many many ways boys know
from very early on that they're not
allowed to be vulnerable they're not
allowed to be weak they're not allowed
to show that because if they do then
people will pick on them and so I guess
if we can teach boys that they're able
to access those emotions firstly and
teach them how to articulate them then
the outcomes for them will be completely
different the piece that's missing is
often like the option to like do
whatever you want to be yourself you
have to see yourself either in the
cinema or in books or in art
young people today are very astute and
are throwing away a lot of the old ideas
about gender norms I think you know very
much at the the beginning of a real sea
change in terms of gender understanding
and openness
I think frozen was a really great
example I know it was very exciting when
that film came out and it was such a
huge phenomenon that it had two girls as
the leads and the folks and story was on
their relationship as sisters and they
saved each other and that was something
that was only a subtle difference you
were still looking at some very pretty
animated girls but actually the kernel
of that story was something quite
different writers are working within the
traditional storytelling format but
actually trying to push the boundaries
within that of the conventions that were
used to and I'm definitely conscious to
try and give them an option and I
secretly like it when they'll go for
since this may be seen as opposite
what's interesting is we're happy to see
female characters being presented in a
more diverse way but wait at all the
nurturing catering sensitive boy
characters there's still a bit of a way
to go in terms of representing boys like
that oh Emily I think the stories that
we tell become the realities that we
live and it has been that way for
thousands and thousands of years if we
change the stories that we're telling
the the lives that we live we look very
different we're at a point where we have
the power to reimagine those things and
completely change the script for a
generation that's very
thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe and click the bail to receive
notifications for new videos see you
again soon